two australian journalists have now
returned home from china after being
embroiled
in a five-day diplomatic standoff
between beijing
and australia michael smith of the
australian financial review
and bill bertles from the public
broadcaster abc
had sheltered in australian diplomatic
missions following raids on their homes
before their departure they were
questions by chinese authorities about
the case of an australian tv
anchor working for chinese state tv
it was feared they would be arrested as
political pawns in the rapidly worsening
relationship between the two countries
smith and bertels were the last two
representatives of australian mainstream
media
in china and for more now we are joined
by bill bertos
one of the australian journalists who
left china welcome to the program and
thank you so much for joining us
if you could just outline for us the
events that led to you
leaving china
yeah sarah thank you this was a pretty
unexpected situation but uh just as
i was preparing to break the story of
the other of the detained australian
chiang lai last
monday um my bosses here in sydney
received a call from australia's foreign
affairs department
uh saying we have good reason to think
that i
and and other journalists in shanghai
need to get out quickly
and for the first couple of days it's
pretty hard to get flights with covered
so while arrangements were being made we
were also
questioning where this advice was coming
from you know being journalists were
pretty cynical and we want some details
but
on wednesday night it became clear at
midnight
when six state security police plus a
translator turned up on my doorstep
the most curious thing was they weren't
there to detain me they were there to
tell me that i'm involved in a national
security case and therefore i'm not
allowed to leave the country
but they said you still have freedom of
movement you're still free to go around
and do your
do your whatever your business uh but
they
said we will call you the next day and
we need to chat
and this sort of sparked a diplomatic uh
situation where of course i went to the
australian embassy and said what's your
advice what do you think
my rights are and they said we think you
should stay here for your safety
and you you mentioned that you were
going to do some reporting on the case
of chiang lai
um that that's potentially why you've
been targeted here
we know that she has not been charged
she's being held under what is called
residential surveillance
at a designated location reportedly
this is an anchor who was the face of
chinese state
media's english service she's an
australian citizen what do you think
happened here
well i'm not even 100 convinced that
the uh situation with myself and the
other journalists in shanghai mike smith
is actually related to chenglai's case
that was the pretext
for police questioning us they basically
said
we need to interrogate you in relation
to
chenglai's case which they ultimately
ended up doing
at the conclusion of this diplomatic
standoff the deal basically was
um the police will interview me
and then the chinese government will
lift its exit ban but having gone
through that interview
i'm not really convinced that police
thought that i or the other journalist
would have any particularly useful
information
it seems to me this is much more related
to the broader problems
in the china-australia relationship and
that perhaps
we were just pawns in a much bigger
situation that's beyond our control so
do you think australians are then being
targeted now
well certainly because the only two
australian media journalists left in
beijing where in china were the only two
who were targeted
to be questioned about this case and
then when we were actually questioned
they weren't particularly rigorous in
trying to extract answers around that
case
meanwhile this particular news reader
changle
i do know her but there are people
including australians in china
who know her a lot better but none of
them are being hauled in
and interrogated so if anything this
looked like a concerted effort
to target the australian media in
beijing
and i'd say that is related more to the
australia china relationship
and there are now no representatives of
the australian mainstream media
in china how problematic do you see this
being considering the close economic
relationship
that the two countries have
well the relationship is uh is awful to
be honest between australia and china at
the moment it's probably the worst it
has been in
since they resumed ties back in the
1970s
it's not going to get any better any
anytime soon because
both sides are increasingly forming a
view of each other that they can't
there's no trust and i can't see a way
to
resolve it um so in the meantime yes
there won't be
australian journalists there i think
that does a great disservice
to australian audiences but also to
china too it doesn't do
china any favors to have you know less
information less exchange and less
understanding of what's going on there
bill bertles journalist joining us to
tell your story
we thank you so much for sharing that
here on dw news